what's up
we going to watch brooklyn 99 202 today
guys you know all the crap that we
always say just hit that freaking like
button all right that's all i'm going to
ask today just hit it
hit it
dang it hit it you like it thanks you'll
love it thanks proper prepper paper
for
adding down the highlights just hit the
like button just hit it
and then watch the video thrice more
we're done with the intro just to hit
the like button stop telling me
just do one thing
thanks doctor
have a good one
hey there sarge not to pry but i
couldn't help but overhear you going to
the doctor i'm getting a vasectomy oh
you're gonna let some quack doctor just
knife around down there you were blessed
with a great power
and you should never snip its wings
thanks guys that's enough i don't need
any more input neither does your wife i
guess
sergeant wants to chop off his penis
that is his
if you guys don't get that i'm gonna
start firing detectives and blanks
sorry satiago
sergeant is this going to go on your
permanent record
playing scrotal recall
i wonder if that was a bunch of improv
i can't think of any to add on
that's nuts
that you couldn't think of so
want to hop on the case with me we're a
killer team jeffords and peralta jake
and terry chocolate and milk i mean i'm
the chocolate and you're the milk you're
so full of protein don't be mad just do
the case
i need to be back in a few hours to
catch my ride to the doctors my neighbor
is driving me because my wife's out of
town with the girls why don't i drive
you i don't know that's that's a good
idea i will be your friend chariot to
the penis removal of the century
the new nypd commissioner is planning a
complete reorganization of the force
boyle diaz i want the evidence room
organized beyond reproach
santiago when i greet the deputy chief i
want you there by my side to make a good
impression no offense but you are
something of a teacher's bed
none taken people love their pets
can you think of anyone who might want
to harm you
yeah i didn't have proof but the guy who
did this to me is my business partner
gregory phillips he still pissed at me
because i banned him from my strong
strunt
using that try this all right here we go
finally all right
oh
oh that's so bitter what's wrong with
this chocolate milk oh
the bitterness of the chocolate brings
out the sourness in the milk that's the
worst part of both of those things
so gross
okay sarge i hate to be that kind of a
friend but let's go chop off that penis
[Laughter]
my sister was gonna go with me to an
engagement party but she had to cancel
so go along it's my ex-wife eleanor's
engagement party i can't go alone word
it might seem a little pathetic
yeah if only you could have gone with
your sister
[Laughter]
are you thinking what i'm thinking no
you could go with me can't i have a date
tomorrow night okay i will figure
something out maybe if i pay my neighbor
joanne she'll ditch her wife for the
night
hello raymond
that is not jennifer jason
but you know
it's deputy chief watch now
unsurprisingly i've been promoted above
you and now i'm here to evaluate you
i will attempt to cooperate with you
under these new circumstances don't
sweet talk me halt
i gave it my best shot let's
begin
hey
how'd it go we weren't able to do the
procedure your friend is so large that
you needed a bigger saw to get through
his dingus
[Music]
physically massive that we didn't have
enough anesthesia on hand
i'm gonna take you home now sarge hey
what do you think of captain holt oh he
needs to smoke some weed
ew your head is so small
no
no so
[Laughter]
you gotta promise me you won't let them
give me the operation i want to have
more kids i don't want the vasectomy
promise me tiny head promise me all
right i promise
i'm not done with my testicles
[Music]
uh oh walk of shame same clothes as
yesterday i slept at the sarges it was
horrible
oh no
all right let's get going and interview
that suspect i have my makeup vasectomy
this afternoon so i'm sorry your what
what vasectomy last night you told me
you didn't want that then you fell on
top of me and changed the shape of my
skeleton forever
no i definitely want one that was the
drugs talking did i do this and call you
tiny head yes some things are coming
back to me now
uh-oh it made me promise to not let him
get that surgery and it wasn't just the
drugs he doesn't want this as his friend
it's my job to stop him
[Laughter]
sorry terry turned my spine into a loose
stack of pebbles
[Laughter]
two-toned grass you think you can
distract me from this precinct's
problems with a flashy presentation i'm
off to do some spot checks
oh my god she's totally gonna flunk us i
haven't gotten enough since i failed
recess in second grade
when we first met we had some good times
[Music]
looks like we both want that stapler
[Laughter]
offered to write a letter on my behalf
but instead she torpedoed me because of
something that happened the night before
she was to turn it in
madeleine
i'm sure you can tell i'm quite drunk
i've had a couple to build up the nerve
i think we both know what i'm about to
say raymond i don't think we need to say
anything
[Music]
i'm gay
she sabotaged my career because i
refused to
bed her
where were you on monday around 10 p.m
me and my business school buddies get
together every monday and have a couple
beers look i left around 10. took the
subway home got off at york street
around my house puked on a statue went
to bed
[Laughter]
do some cop stuff have a heart-to-heart
about your vasectomy cancel your
vasectomy grab some drinks laugh about
the time you almost got a vasectomy stop
worrying about my vasectomy man
maybe you should focus on your own body
when's the last time you had a carrot
well it's my least favorite type of cake
so rarely
thank you for coming i wasn't sure if
you'd get my message charles it was kind
of hard to miss
oh
my ex-wife's throwing an engagement
party this weekend and i was wondering
if you wanted to go as friends no
charles just because we have secret
shameful sex does not mean we are
friends here get friends let's go with
bone bros
have you seen this man around dark milk
oh i don't go there they don't allow
babies in there what is wrong with them
all i drink when i was a baby was
chocolate milk
thank you for your time and thank you
adorable little baby who's probably
giving my partner some mixed feelings
right about now
oh no operation sarge instead make a
tiny muscular friend for me to play with
that's enough i'm with you that's enough
baby mind your own business
i haven't heard of dark milk and i've
never seen this man before this is your
league why are we here well according to
the internet dr mendel is the best
couples counselor in the park slope area
who accepts sanjay walk-ins
look i'm sorry okay but the things you
said when you were whacked out were real
you made me promise and as your friend i
told you jake we're not that kind of
friend
not what kind of friends friend friends
oh
not good enough
prepare to be physically overpowered by
a friend friend
[Music]
i've got you you can't move
you have been conquered
needless to say i'm thoroughly
underwhelmed huh from your expression i
would guess
constipated
or chilly excuse us captain
[Laughter]
the letter of recommendation she wrote
for you 25 years ago the letter's very
positive you thought she wrote mean
stuff about you because of the
you thought i cost you that promotion
because you're gay
that's what you've been mad about all
these years i'm mad because you tried to
get me thrown off the force yeah because
you shot me i shot you because you were
in the wrong position you weren't
following orders you embarrassed me in
front of derek jeter you embarrass
yourself
hey rosa better follow me oh no
reggie
what
cornrows i got scarface i'll repeat
i still don't have a date unless this
sweet maize head has changed your mind i
think we both know it hasn't we do
fair enough
well
goodbye raymond
anything you'd like to say to me before
i complete my evaluation something in
the form of groveling never
fail me if you must
you're just gonna let her fail us
that grade is the only thing standing
between me and a future where you're not
my captain anymore
i attempted to cajole her but she
rebuffed me i'm not a man of unlimited
cajoling
this precinct needs you in command
cajole up captain
you better not be trying to talk me out
of my surgery again i think i'm just
here to give you a ride home and to
prove to you once and for all that i'm
more than just a work friend
thank you microscope head
remember gregory said he got off at the
york street station the night of the
stabbing well i took the subway here and
it's closed for construction hmm so what
you're saying is i stabbed him
jake you were right don't want the
surgery tiny hand nypd put down the
scalpel and step away from my work
friend's wiener too
look oh no oh no a good sign
hey mom
oh
hell yeah
here's what's about to happen we're
gonna go to this terrible party i'm
gonna laugh at all your jokes i'm gonna
talk about your medal of valor and i'm
gonna make you look like a jamaican god
of rhythm sebastian little mermaid
respect mon no i'm gonna read to my
toast in the car
you're giving a toast we're like we're
giving a toast oh golly
hey jake i have to tell you something oh
boy i am a little conflicted about
having a vasectomy really is that why
you threw an ekg machine at the time
your tiny head has a big heart inside it
you're a huggy good boyfriend no no no
he'll crack his back though
we received our grade oh my god is this
goodbye there's still so much i have to
say to you 2.7 mediocre
but enough for you to stick around
all right that compromise everything i
stand for you are now and always have
been the superior police officer
and oh the derek jeter thing was my
fault
[Music]
this is the best job i've ever had and
it would be foolish to give it up over a
petty feud it's a great for your
performance these past two days a letter
grade so as to not be weird about it
oh my god you really shouldn't have
and hey
oh
amy
i just talked to my wife we're waiting
in operation thanks for taking care of
me i got you a little present
now eat your carrot
i'll rip your tiny head off no no come
here no
i hate being friends with you
that was
kira sedgwick ah yes it was in a tiny
thumb i could have sworn it was not
curious
i thought you were spot on the money it
was jennifer jason lee yeah that she
showed like that is definitely not
my bad it's all good all right guys
let's break down the philosophy of
brooklyn nine-nine this is wisecrack
what is the true meaning of french
should you get a vasectomy
depends
in 1948 such obscure
scholar it depends if you should get of
a second it does it does it does you
should absolutely be like transparent
and talk to your wife the way terry
ultimately learned to do by the end of
this episode or whoever you know you're
considering conceiving what a man does
with his body is not his wife's concern
you know i i was wrong there i'm sorry
where's our rights
it's men
uh
yeah that was good man that was good my
my approach when watching this show
a very specific reaction approach
at two minutes i will laugh
every two minutes give left to right to
space out the fairy user ruler and every
three and a half minutes make a comment
uh
i don't um
i make sure it sounds weird sounds like
it's the weirdest thing to take it's
like well yeah of course what else do
you do
but sometimes when people watch comedies
or something you know you might like
laugh a little bit more than you
normally would and i'm just more like no
i'm only gonna laugh whenever
i it just comes out of me because it's
genuinely really funny
and uh yeah this show is [ __ ] making
me laugh a lot because every year i try
i attempt to do something somewhere
where i'm just like lego relax and yeah
if it makes you laugh then lean into
that and and yeah like every time i find
myself just like kind of lulling in in
my face going back to rest point someone
does something really funny yeah like
it's just a great ensemble and some
really sharp writing it's a funny ass
show man that is uh that's brilliant and
uh i love the
i love the
camaraderie with
holt and not holt yeah no
all of them everyone like everyone and
they're all great
peralta and terry terry it reminded me
of the last episode of one before
because you'd said that before and it
was like they'd heard you they were like
more terry and peralta episodes
were they in that oh they were yeah they
got they must have been a producer's
writers room meeting if they're doing
two episodes in a row after season one
they were like okay this this dynamic
works a lot where the producers were
like the nielsen rating suggests from
the poll that
fan favorites are terry
and peralta so we should
we should have them do more scenes
together and a hundred people hashtag to
terry and perez
social media keeping our finger on the
pulse
yeah i love the camaraderie here and
learning you know how to be
friend friends outside of work see john
i did the opposite we were friend
friends
after that
and then we'll find ourselves in a
friend friend moment and be like oh how
do we do this once this channel hits a
million subs and then we terminate it we
pull the lever down and then
only doing fred fresh
soul channel's gone
deleted this is the new unisonist except
it's just one million subs and it took
way longer
tennis honestly whatever the latin for
ten yeah which i should know
that's a good moral to have good deal i
i love the dilemmas that it puts terry
in is because there's not really
a lot of sitcoms rely heavily on um
dating or relationship
troubles you know like people who are
either really into each other but aren't
hooking up like kind of like peralta and
amy or
who are very much in a relationship and
then you're kind of exploring and
dealing with that
and what i noticed with this show is no
one's really has that like that as a
focal point
but they give a lot of that to terry
as like a husband and wife who've been
together for so long yeah but yeah you
don't get a lot with terry and his wife
you're going on like one episode yeah
but he keeps having like serious marital
things to deal with
that normally you you could see elements
of that in a traditional sitcom
but it's more amusing to see it from the
perspective where it's how their work
friends working with terry as he's
dealing with it so i think that's like a
really funny way to approach something
that
would generally be a pro because like
with sitcoms it really became popular
through like family sitcoms you know
and uh watching husband and wife and
being like haha that's like uh sunscreen
yeah so you know uh to not have that
here as a prevalent reoccurring motif
it's pretty cool to
get it in this form and also handle more
mature stuff like a vasectomy is a
pretty mature thing to handle yeah well
i think that's the that's the juju that
makes the show juju that's what they
call okay
so yeah the stuff that makes the show
work i think especially well is because
yeah you have all like the police
procedural workplace things to bounce
off of and make humor out of but more
and more and more i feel like my
favorite episodes and i'm curious to see
how the show progresses because in
season one there would be episodes that
more clearly had like very personal
stories happening with the police stuff
as the kind of backdrop or as sort of a
sidebar and i feel like you know in an
episode like this
most all the stories were like you know
personal things even dealing with some
element of a serialized character trait
or joke and uh
yeah i feel like those make for the
strongest episodes and i can imagine
maybe they'll lean further into that
stuff like making it
doing a lot with the family dynamics of
this little group as well as all the you
know police situation comedy yeah well
they give the family vibe to the to the
police say to the precinct yeah
uh just like how holt looks out for
amy in that one in a lot of ways it was
kind of you see these like little
dynamic shifts like amy standing up to
holt in a really bold manner a way that
she wouldn't have done so before yeah i
thought that was good getting that uh
that robust attitude yeah yeah yeah like
great like it's gotta matter more than
pleasing hope yeah good motivation
well i love the comp the competitive
nature between uh him and uh kyra said
carouse that's right curious edward
manningham curacao jennifer jason lee
we're just gonna call her jennifer jason
from here on out yeah could have sworn
with jennifer jesus they really did i
can attest and the thumbnail you look at
her right and you're like yeah cause
especially as they've aged they they
look more similar yeah let me see
jennifer jason lee today
jennifer jason lee 20
21
yeah man far away they do look similar
yeah cheekbones yeah the lips yeah yeah
structures i think far away they do look
like in a small little the way we see it
in a small little way that they do look
somewhere and now someone should cast
them in some kind of raunchy sister
comedy where they play two sisters
that would be great it would be a box
office smash that independently yeah
yeah
that's the thing that made to break the
records yeah um
yeah like their their chemistry together
is great it's cool to give them a foil
for someone who is a a female
counterpart too you know and it's cool
to get the dynamic in that regard where
it's nice seeing male female dynamic
that is this butting heads that doesn't
rely at all on sexual tension yeah
actually like negates that and i
appreciate it that she's like that's the
one thing about you i actually respect
the rest of this is yeah where all of
our attention and release comes from
that was great yeah and then of course
freaking boy i keep teasing boyle and
rosa possibly becoming a thing well
that's the thing too is they i i am
it's so hot yeah it was good it was she
she did the jamaican appropriation way
better than charm
which is funny too because it's it's
interesting to see how you know the show
ages and luckily it's supposed to be
cringe so it you know flies but um no i
got problems uh you should it's
absolutely unacceptable
but uh no also i admire kind of in a way
and i'm
continually curious that they have yeah
they they have they don't rely so much
on like will they want the romantic
tension even though they they have it
like because you have peralta and amy
and you have rosa and boyle and they're
both on these sort of like no they're
they're each seeing other people at the
moment and these things may happen down
the line but it doesn't seem like it
seems like the point is not to rush
toward them yeah and so like that also
creates kind of an interesting sense of
i don't know
i don't know when it'll happen and it
kind of feels like it's happening more
organically than like we got to
prioritize this as a plot line you know
yeah that's so true
all right guys well i think john's done
talking so let's wrap this video up so
thanks i i pride myself on the breakdown
of 20 minute
confidence so good that's what you're
here for thanks for being here guys hey
hit that like button hit the like button
do it like us subscribe you know hit the
like button this person who's gonna get
up
tyler haig i wanted to shout you out on
this episode i don't know if you watched
this show but to me out of everyone at
patreon shout out you were easily the
terriest of everyone at the patreon i
mean you could easily fold me in half
bench me you know throw me down a
bowling alley and have like a comedic
pin sound or you could take i could have
to be your friend trying to talk you out
of the vasectomy and what am i gonna do
you're just gonna drag me right down the
street but you also got a heart of gold
you're the sweetest guy you're gentle
you're loving and i miss the old days of
uh getting on the little google hangouts
with you man and seeing your uh
architect wall of screens that you live
under i hope you're getting some
sunlight and we'll talk soon thanks for
being here and much love buddy
you know what i would have said what
would you have said
[Music]